one of the things that i think politics
systematically
under rates and importance and and tends
to be very bad at talking about is
technological change just
in general how important it is what is
happening with it
we functionally live in a gerundocracy
where um i think nancy pelosi is
80 trump is 74. joe biden is 77.
mitch mcconnell is in the upper 70s i
think he might be 77.
like this is not the most tech forward
leadership
group you could possibly imagine and so
a lot of what is changing in technology
which is really important i think it
gets
underplayed so let's have a little bit
of a conversation
there ai how has your thinking changed
on it in the past few years
compared to you know two years ago or
whatever it was when we talked
do you think the landscape there has
changed um do you think there are things
people should know that have happened
a lot of the things i was concerned
about have
now come into full view because of the
pandemic
and you know that companies that were
considering investing
in ai and robotic meat packers and the
rest of it
and robot aisle cleaners in the grocery
store
now those companies are accelerating the
investments
and the example i use is that
now if you get a domino's pizza and a
self-driving car
you're excited because you had less
human contact whereas before it seemed a
little bit creepy
um same with the self-checkout aisle and
if you look at ai that there's this new
release that now
can do a lot of writing and basic
summaries on a level that's
indistinguishable from
human journalists you're talking here
about open eyes gpt-3 yeah
yeah yeah open the eyes uh gpt3 so if
people haven't heard of this i'm going
to put in show notes
my colleague kelsey piper did a great
piece on this but it's
surreal let me put it that way but what
it's able to do in terms of language
processing is
wild and two years ago if you'd asked me
hey
is software gonna get to this point i
would say i would have said yes
um but then you could still argue over
it you know what i mean uh and
now two years later it's here and
you can see the commercial potential of
this technology
one of the reasons why i was so
concerned about the impact of ai on our
labor force ezra is that i know
how many frankly inefficient jobs
there are in a lot of these major
companies where if you gobble up another
company
and you have two different systems you
might keep
dozens even hundreds of folks around
just to keep the systems talking to each
other
there's a lot of weird stuff when you
get into the bowels of some of these
organizations uh and i knew that over
time
ai could end up making a lot of those
types of jobs
less and less central the arguments
about
human labor and ai they tend to be
non-market driven and kind of romantic
you'd be like oh you know
like you can ever replace a human who
does what ezra does or
what andrew does or what not but
you know a lot of our work is more
replaceable than we like to think
and what's funny is if you ask americans
about this they will actually say a
majority of other people's jobs are
automatable and subject to technological
replacement and then if you ask them
about their own job the vast majority
will say not my job uh you know that's
just the way we're wired
it's why i'm fleeing to the high ground
of podcasting i mean they're going to
come for the calmness way before they
come for the podcasters
it's much much definitely much harder
for ai to have a good conversation than
for it to just write up a
write up a take on the gdp report anyone
anyone like us we're already at the top
of the pyramid you know what i mean like
if you have a podcast with a significant
audience
you're you're you've already made it to
a certain point like and if you think
about all the
folks who are coming of age right now
like the younger versions of us who are
graduating from college right now it's
like you know it's
the winner take all economy applies in
many spaces including
uh the ones that you and i occupy oh
absolutely i want to talk about
something else
a lot of the problems that i care most
about solving they have a huge
technological dimension to them
i care a lot about animal suffering and
by far the most uh
promising way to do something about that
is plant and cell based meat
care a lot about climate change and
while i've had saul griffith on the show
talking about how we could fix climate
change without anything
any new technology being invented
there's just no doubt that given
the level of mandate and adoption and
take up that we'll need
if we can invent some great new stuff it
would become a lot easier
ai often gets talked about in a dystopic
way but if we really could invent it
it could make life pretty amazing and
one of the things that has struck me
is that i don't think progressives in
general
have much of a theory of technology
anymore um
i think that it's often talked about in
this dystopic way there's a lot of
frustration at the billionaires who who
own it
i often felt you sort of like oscillated
between like a very scary story about ai
and then also like a real
interest in technology as a way of
solving problems and i'd love to just
hear you reflect on that like what
should
what do you think the political
orientation to technology in general
should be
i love where you are on this ezra like i
i think that ideally
progressives are for progress and you
know what
is going to enable a ton of progress is
technology and one of the fun things
about
um my campaign was i was making some
very dark arguments about the impact of
technology which i completely believe uh
you know like
if you have autonomous trucks in the
next you know i'll extend the timeline
because i know you and i differ on this
but
like let's say like 20 years you know
like there'll be
millions of folks who uh used to drive a
truck for a living
who you know will need something else to
do so i like i believe all of that
wholeheartedly
uh but i also agree with you that if
you're trying to make people smarter
healthier mentally healthier uh trying
to clean up our planet
uh trying to feed people in a way that
doesn't brutalize animals
technology is a part of every single one
of those solutions
in a very central way and the one of the
dangers to me
about a lot of our politics now is we're
each arguing for different brands of
nostalgia
you know what i mean you know meanwhile
time only goes in one direction
you know it's 2020. you're now out in
california
like i spent a lot of time there and
you go to some of the folks who are
working on the future and it is
wild like some of the things that
they're working on are very
um positive and inspirational uh some of
them are very depressing and dystopian
but they're all packaged together and we
should not be a group of people or a
party
that also has our heads in the sand
about the
positive and negative changes that
technology brings like we have to be the
party that
is hard-nosed and realistic but also
willing to embrace the
technologies that could lead us to
something that
more closely resembles utopia than this
current
mess we're living uh so i i love what
you just said ezra like uh you know i
completely agree
like we need to be embracing these
technologies at a much higher level and
i'm i may be a part of that
in this next administration if um you
know
if we succeed in getting trump out of
there wait uh i want to follow up on
that tantalizing
i may be a part of that um is there a
job you've been talking about
oh so i've had just very very general
informal conversations with uh
the bind camp about trying to take on
some sort of technology-facing role
both some of the concerns that i
campaigned on and trying to address them
and one thing we haven't talked about
but i'm very passionate about that you
will be
too in a few years is the effect of
uh social media and technology on our
kids mental health you know like right
now you have massive levels of anxiety
and depression among teenage girls in
particular
in order to make uh certain companies
like facebook richer
which you know is not a good look but
our government is way behind the curve
on these issues
and i've offered my help in trying to
catch us up
and there's some interest in taking me
up on that
and so so then to go back to this
underlying question
you said something i thought that's
worth picking up on about you've talked
to people in silicon valley and you go
look at what they're doing and some of
it is very utopian and some of it
is very dystopian and i've had probably
some of the same conversations with even
some of the same people you have and
what always strikes me
is that it's not in most cases
intrinsic to the technology which way
that plays out and oftentimes
it is actually about the way the
government and
both the rules of markets and and
regulations
but also to some degree government
implementation taxation etc
is going to interface with the
technology that's going to decide
whether it ends up being like utopian or
dystopian
and so there sometimes seems to me to be
a more obvious
approach here which is that i would say
that it should be a more central
priority
frankly for both parties to use the
government as a research
and innovation accelerant but then it
also has to be a more central
priority again hopefully for both
parties for
the government to have views and to care
about how the technology is rolled out
who has access to it and also what rules
it operates
under yeah that it's spot on ezra
and right now our government is
out to lunch on most of these technology
issues and
we need to change it you know and i
agree with you this should be central
for both parties
because the rate of change is just
getting faster and faster
we got rid of the office of technology
assessment in 1995
25 years ago and we can all sense that
well there was no more technology oh
yeah no we invented everything 95.
ended in 95. it's embarrassing really
and we can all sense it like
everyone just has this collective grown
when it comes to government and
technology
and then again you have something like
healthcare.gov where you're like oh no
like they tried to make a website you
know
i mean i should have laughed because it
was freaking terrible so if you were
helping to modernize government on
technology in a in a
future administration how would you
think about that where where would you
start what would
what would be the kinds of things you
would imagine doing
you would ramp up the united states
digital service and empower it and
you and i both know that there are
hundreds maybe even thousands
of very talented technologists
designers coders who would help
government if they had a runway to do so
and felt like they could actually be
empowered as opposed to going into
sitting in
meetings and getting their hands tied in
red tape and bureaucracy and the rest of
it
so that would be step one you take
what's been working and then you pour
fuel on it that the the other thing i
would be trying to do is
i think that there should be some kind
of west coast base of operation and part
of the talent
enlistment move because there are a lot
of techies that might not want to uproot
their families
and head to dc so you need to give them
a a place to
reside and land and then we need to have
actual experts get into the guts of the
social media companies and the apps
because each of these companies
is its own thing like you can't really
have one size fits all for example 20th
century anti-trust rules when it comes
to
you know facebook and instagram and the
rest of it though i do think that they
should not have allowed them to
acquire instagram um but that there
there are all of these features that are
companies
specific that you need real expertise to
try and get to the bottom of
and see if you can curb the worst of the
excesses
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you